hey guys what's going on welcome to the
seventh Bitcoin trading video I'm gonna
put this video out before a brief hiatus
with the Bitcoin trading videos I'm
gonna begin working on some machine
learning to use with Bitcoin trading see
if there's really anything there and
that might take me a while so that's I
don't know I don't know how long it'll
be but anyway this would be kind of like
a short break after this video so the
first thing I want to do is show you
guys real quickly how to connect to the
API so you can start streaming prices if
you really did want to start trading or
maybe working on something that notifies
you when the RSI hits a certain value
and so on so the the API for them is
going to be put the link in the
description but here is the example of
their API so it's btc-e comm slash api /
- slash BTC USD or whatever ratio you
wanted to use and then ticker and let me
just see if I can squish it over a
little bit so what we can do though is
you can see all the prices the high the
low the volume currently the last and
then the Buy and the sell and then the
last updated so we can hit this and we
should see at least last probably will
update so 93 12 will do it again
we're not seeing any updates yet or
delasco yeah well the service normally
this one updates like super fast or not
there we go at least something updated
normally this updates like extremely
quick you can spam the heck out of them
too but anyway you can see it's changing
so what you want to do is just have your
script constantly checking this and so
we do see it is indeed changing for us
so I'm just gonna show you guys how to
get the last price because that's really
what we're mostly interested in but
obviously you can use this method for
really getting any price so let's go
ahead and import what we need we're
going to need time because we're gonna
be using time we're gonna need
well that's let's see I think the only
the only other thing we're gonna want is
JSON really we just need time in JSON I
think so now we want to do is visit that
website so and actually I guess we'll
need URL it too so important URL or L
live too and so what we're gonna want to
say is we're just going to just just
real even easily we're gonna make just a
define name here then we're gonna say
btc-e prices equals URL Lib to URL open
and I'm just gonna take this URL and
just copy and paste it in here I'll put
the link in the description for you guys
that's the URL then we want to go ahead
and read it fix this okay so now what
we're going to say now is btc-e JSON
equals JSON
loads and we just want to load in VP TCG
prices then we're going to say the last
price is going to be btc-e last P equals
btc-e JSON and then what we want to get
in here is ticker if you recall the
first element in this dictionary I was
corrected last time I called them a
multi-dimensional list it's a
multi-dimensional dictionary anyway use
ticker and then after ticker what are we
looking for well we're looking for last
so that's fairly easy so ticker than
last and that'll give us the price and
then just just in case we really want it
we can grab the time to over here T
equals btc-e JSON and again we want
ticker and do we want last or do we want
server time or do we want updated well
server time is just whatever the time is
at that moment of your refresh updated
is the last time it was updated so we
want updated not server time so we'll
throw this in and we'll say updated
and that's really it so now we could
just print btc-e I'm just going to throw
in last price I'm not really gonna do
the time thing so that's that and you
could also just like instead of using
their time you can use your own time so
it's like your local time or whatever or
you don't even need time at all you can
do it however you want to do it that's
just kind of how you can do it that way
so now we'll just have it run Maine and
I'm just gonna say while true Maine time
sleep one second okay so we are gonna
just ping the crap out of this website
so we're seeing 917 917 no one will
continue doing it but anyway we're
streaming these prices earlier actually
btc-e did indeed go down looked like
they're getting a DDoS but it sure would
be nice updated to something else
besides oo one or the whole 917 so
anyways that's that's how you can
connect to that one the mountain blocks
API is very similar there's a lot more
data in the mountain Cox API for each
call but basically this you know the
process to pull these prices is very
very similar um so anyways that's how
you can do that now there's a couple
other things I want to show you guys for
I conclude I am gonna stop this so we're
not hitting them so much and the only
other thing I really wanted to show you
guys is like when you go onto btc-e
you'll see that if you scroll down a
little bit you can see what people's
offers are here right you don't get that
really in this stock market right you
don't get to see unless you're an
exchange you don't get to see what
people's offers are but you can see all
of the buy orders currently so like this
guy's buying 14.6 bitcoin right for
$13,000 and this guy over here we've got
people buying and selling Bitcoin and
and it shows you kind of like with at
least on here kind of the size of the
offer by you know bold normal and kind
of like dim right for a little
itty-bitty baby amounts the kind of
stuff that I've been trading FN like for
for manly amounts
got that here and then on this one you
can see here that there's a very large
resistance at 9:25 because there are
four hundred and thirty coins in for
that price that's their earlier there
was five hundred twenty five and now
there's only four thirty so it did
actually hit that price for a little bit
but it didn't stay there very long and
then it ended up going down and so just
a good way to kind of visualize this is
there is a charting website that has
actually already done it so let me pull
them over here this website is Bitcoin
wisdom dot-com and to get to this exact
chart slash market slash btc-e slash
btc-e USD but they also have it for
amount gah spit stamp and so on and you
can see here that they actually chart
the future offers right so we have all
the buy offers here we've got all the
sell offers here so you can actually see
the offers and I'm not positive but I
believe the length white like the size
of the bar is the size of the offer kind
of like it's a kind of in relation right
so these are all little itty bitty
offers so it'd be really easy to pass
these a little harder to pass these very
hard to pass this one same thing going
down this way very hard or hardest to
pass this one easy easy easy easy hard
ish super easy so like if you were like
holding right at this point you might
want to go ahead and sell before it
reaches this point because if it breaks
at this point it's going way down right
and so you can trade based on that
information and that's the kind of
information that you could never have
traded on in the actual like stock
market because you don't have that data
all right nobody has access to future
order data besides the exchanges and
I've never seen that data that you can
even buy you know you got to be in with
the in-crowd you know to get that kind
of information so that's really neat
information to have and so that's kind
of a good idea to maybe start reading
into that data and getting your hands on
that data and plotting and trading based
on that kind of information so anyway
that's gonna conclude the video I'll
just leave it at that and this is a
pretty nice website I was actually
pretty happy with their charting
application it's pretty nice the data is
indeed real-time I compared it to my
real-time stream and it means
it's right on there so if you wanted to
use a chart I'd kind of recommend this
chart so I don't really think I will do
a charting tutorial for this for Bitcoin
at least because this thing covers it
pretty well and they even have these
futuristic offers that I really like so
that's pretty neat so anyways that's
gonna conclude this video hopefully you
guys have enjoyed hopefully you guys are
interested in Bitcoin so I think it's a
really interesting topic for sure and
you can trade it with all kinds of
information that you never really were
able to trade any markets on so it's
pretty neat so anyways that's going to
conclude this video if you have enjoyed
the series I do have a donation link
down at the bottom so you can donate
some Bitcoin if you want otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions until
next time